here to help us is a snake expert it's
steve london
um also known as the new jersey snake
man
now is that a moniker you might have put
in a post-it on your mirror when you
were younger totally yeah absolutely
i've been into it since i was four so
definitely oh so you found your path
yeah there were some curves along the
way but yeah for sure there always is
um well i'm excited for you um to teach
us about different snakes i'd like to
learn about them and their personalities
um so first we're gonna get into this
little cute snake what is its name so
his name is carrot cake and uh this is a
corn snake
and craig is going to get down with the
card
he likes the dating profile is there
anything we need to know about this
snake likes dislikes habits uh so they
like to eat rodents they live in uh pine
forests for the most part how big do
they get uh so that's a that's an adult
male they get to be about three feet as
males the females are actually bigger
than the males
so they can top out around females are
bigger than the males huh
bigger stronger
all right give me one thing that would
surprise us about this snake one detail
uh it's actually the most popular pet
snake in the world
oh wow that's a good detail
now craig will you give us a detail
about killing it one per snake
yes yes i
i i'm a python hunter and killing it
sorry kid
and like if i i do it to to to raise
money because i'm about that american
dream i love it okay um next we have a
boa constrictor named bigwig
oh yeah
oh yeah
is that the one you feel that i might be
a match with
i mean he is an outdoorsy guy um
give me his dating profile for sure
if he had arms he would be into kayaking
for sure but mostly i love kayaking it's
perfect it's a match made in heaven may
i absolutely is that okay your hands are
on your shoulders um
there we go all right maybe i could
brittany this up oh for sure
[Applause]
i'm in
um
tell me a detail about my future
boyfriend
he's a really cheap date uh he would
only he he would only eat probably
four to six times a year and
and is it like uh like a muskrat does he
eat something really large when he eats
uh basically the in the wild to leave
the biggest thing that'll fit in their
mouth so it's kind of like thanksgiving
every time yeah loosen their belt head
back and go to sleep now craig will you
tell us another detail about maybe your
relationships with snakes on the show
you seemed very comfortable were you
always comfortable with snakes or no i
was you know what i was in australia
in uh
about 2016 with my band
and that's where i got over my fear
snakes because i was about to take a
picture with a band member had a snake
and i was going to act like i was scared
to get close and then actually i touched
the snake and it was it felt so amazing
ended up letting them put it around my
neck and and i was like this snake means
you no harm you've been lied to by the
bible and indiana jones
so um all right let's bring out our
third snake um this is going to give you
some britney vibes she made this one
famous at the vmas it's a python
wow
these guys are from southeast asia and
myanmar um used to be burma uh so they
like it real warm
and they and they tend to spend a lot of
time in sort of swampy areas
ah
i mean he is really gorgeous and i was
just telling everybody at the commercial
break how much yellow is the color of
our show because it's such an optimistic
color
[Applause]
oh
i feel like i just swiped left on one
and right on another that's okay they're
both outdoorsy i i feel like a two-timer
i don't know how to describe this
sensation
craig you describe the sensation of
manhandling
a very large snake
it's like a
i mean because this is
boy is this different even than the boa
it's like being tickled by a hot dog
well would you like a giant kielbasa
that could possibly like strangle you
sure wanna can we trade is that possible
let's make it
whoa
i just want everyone to note the leg
just want everyone to note
the rapid i
i really
there is like the sense that this could
kill me
so quickly
so fast
but like it's exciting because i'm
trusting so much that it won't but there
is no question that it could
oh sure absolutely
um you guys uh one last detail um craig
what is the latest post-it that you
would put on your mirror or affirmation
for yourself right now
i will say uh
it's yours
well
craig
and steve thank you so much for what has
been such a beautiful fun awesome dope
segment this is my kind of jam
really and truly
thank you thank you and
killing it premieres today
on peacock get it while it's hot it is
so much fun craig robinson i have loved
you for so long um
may we just live in a world with more
craig robinson
[Applause]
[Music]
you